we're still in love like it's a you  high-five would you still like each  other so Mila Kunis and Ashton Kutcher  are madly in love but that doesn't mean  they went crazy spending money on their  wedding day turns out their wedding  bands that were dirt cheap I decided to  just get them off of Etsy and so our  wedding bands are from Etsy and then I  went and looked at like how much - I was  like what there how much like this is  astronomical and so I went on Betsy  knows like $90 I was like buy now and  then the band that I'll wear for the  rest of my life now you know how is  everybody yeah he led mates Ashton's  band was a little more pricey coming in  at 10 bucks higher had $100 now the star  does also have a large diamond  engagement ring but that's beside the  point  right dad